everybody has at least one special
talent a penchant proclivity or just
thing that defines who we are as people
for some it's winning one versus four
and he's gonna get a head shot follow oh
no way
for others it's wielding gonna come down
to kenny s with the awp 1v3 we can see
where he's looking now just gets the
shot barely on msl finds the second one
yes
blake with the no scope and for a lucky
few it's
wooing
[Music]
but save the sheer size of his signature
titular pythons yaroslav pascha biceps
yarjobkovsky isn't known for any one
thing rather he is an individual of many
talents doesn't look like quick enough
as pronax snacks
in four seconds
tips
now from the outside looking in it seems
like this mountain of a man would be an
unapproachable intimidating killing
machine far removed from all sentiment
but that couldn't be further from the
truth i may suffer from the clinical
depression and tried to communicate
recently but now i'm in love to life
again you have any advice for me for you
for you are my hero and my idol
my friend
counter strike
fix you my friend go to gym fix you find
some gear my friend lovely girl love her
my friend then
good luck baby so how did this
muscle-bound jock become one of the most
wholesome personalities in the entire cs
go community what has pasha been up to
since the fall of the virtus plow and
why the hell did he decide to throw down
with a guy known as
sheep
papito think about tactic guys everyone
probably would like to see rashbee in
octagon
i don't even know what i'm gonna show
guys
okay so before we dive into pasha biceps
do your boy favor like the video
subscribe to the channel and if you want
turn on notifications
if you don't it's fine but you won't be
my friend you'll be my brother my friend
wait that doesn't work
alright it's fair to say that if you
know literally anything about
counter-strike then you know pasha
biceps as one of the following things an
og
1.6r and they're just gonna gang up they
shouldn't be able to uh take this away
from navi
20 seconds to go he actually gets a head
shot in until markaloff looking for the
second one as well he's gonna have to go
for his 12 versus 19 hp plenty of time
and he gets the kill and esc gonna level
us up great play from pascha an
indispensable part of the illustrious
vertus plow he wants to see if it can
get a rotation towards dinner and then
at that point he gets one kill even with
one hp and they've gone past them no
they haven't checked his position passes
down everything correctly here shoots
one gets the double and now two versus
one that robs his left because one hp a
major winner and mvp
an obvious fitness enthusiast
come on
and last but not least
definitely not your friend you are not
my friends my brother is my friend
but in case you are somehow unfamiliar
with pasha's story let me give you a
quick rundown or as quick as you can
expect with someone who's been playing
counter-strike professionally for the
better part of two decades a very good
father very very good football player
the best esports player husband very
handsome sexy he can he can go to any
movie hollywood pasha is a proud pole
who like many of his seasoned storied
peers
first discovered cs while playing with
friends at an internet cafe in his
native town of nazielsk but what was
just a way to pass the time at first
quickly turned into a serious passion
now a lot of you youngans may not
realize this but pasha spent six years
playing 1.6 competitively before
transitioning to global offensive after
it was released in 2012. during that
time pasha got married and as a newly
minted family man had to think twice
about committing to the taxing
tumultuous gamble that is a pro esports
career but luckily for us all pasha's
wife kinga stood by her man and so we
all got to enjoy watching him flex goof
around and cement himself as a force to
be reckoned with we'll leave it in a
four on three post plant but pasha's
quickly on the scene and with low hp on
the player inside pit dupreeh he's gonna
go down as well and pasha's got the hat
trick it's left to just cajun beat and
he eventually will get at least one into
snacks but the fire in place he's got to
stand within it and pasha closes it out
so just do the shot going to try and
defend no nice shot on fur doesn't even
hit the ground at taco low and hp easy
to pick up again maxim jumps up
i can jump two therefore for lucas
still an all-important round and a
massive frag from pasha
gave them a lifeline in the first half
this time you may give them more than
that because he finds a third what a
game while pasha was definitely
relishing the fruits of his competitive
labor on csgo's biggest stages
he was also starting to cement himself
as a pretty beloved content creator his
english might not have been perfect but
the potent mix of clip-worthy gameplay
funny commentary and sheer unadulterated
wholesomeness made his stream the place
to be for many a cs go fan give me this
give me this
headshot
give me one bullet bro for you okay you
soon die my friend give me one headshot
this is easy
if something in your family is
doing
very bad
you should to help your family no
computer
nothing
the mouse
keyboard in the window computer on the
floor
and very fast your family and heaven
remember this it's very important
a real man
should do this
can
if someone's soon cheating valve
probably pay me money for hunting and
papita will be like very dangerous now
even though pasha's personal endeavors
may have been on the up and up by the
end of 2018 virtus pro the team that had
been his home for four years and saw him
achieve countless victories was on a
steady inescapable and altogether
understandable decline but we don't have
like a lot of a lot of days so everyone
know right now is the [ __ ] in our teams
so
let's focus and do our best despite the
team's efforts to make it work by
february of 2019 the old vp was no more
and pasha found himself adrift and
teamless for the first time in years but
just because vp's dissolution
essentially forced pasha into retirement
he had no plans of giving up on esports
entirely so when team liquid approached
him in august of 2020 to join their
roster of content creators he leapt at
the opportunity how are you doing my
friends
[Music]
but if you thought streaming was the
only thing that posha biceps was up to
these days
you'd be sorely mistaken over the years
pasha found himself in a position to
give back to the cs go community and
what better way to do that than to
create the next generation of csgo
greats in his own image
as it happened liquid also saw papito as
something of a father figure and
assigned him a mentorship role in the
org but whoever said that those who
teach
can't do
definitely wasn't talking about pasha
this past fall team liquid had him
registered as their sixth man for the
pgl stockholm major the first time since
his virtus pro days that pasha was
officially willing to lend his legendary
biceps to a pro team on the big stage
and while he didn't get to actually play
there were plenty of people who were
excited that that was even a possibility
which brings me to the whole fighting a
sheep thing i mentioned earlier
obviously fitness has always been a huge
part of pasha's life so much so in fact
that he couldn't even perform at his
best unless he got in a quick pump
before a game sometimes he just played
bad tournaments because there is not
good enough gym at the hotel but when
there is believe me he's playing awesome
so perhaps it should come as no surprise
that at 33 years of age pasha found
himself in a polish mma league scheduled
to meet mihal oftsa or sheep in polish
of charjack a social media fitness
personality in a freaking cage
i i'm gonna be like a representative
esport in the sport i feel sorry for the
other guy yeah
and feel sorry for offside you should
because when fight day finally arrived
papito showed him no mercy on route to a
second round stoppage which she followed
up with a heartwarming post-fight
interview where he thanked the entire
esports community for their undying
support at the end of the day whether
he's fighting in a cage banging in
worldies against brazilians or messing
around on stream seeing pasha on any
stage is a delight for cs go fans
because pasha is just one of those
institutions in counter-strike that's
just
universally loved kimchi because
we looked up to him in 1.6 on the major
stages of cs go watched him shed a manly
tear on his stream saw him enable kids
to pursue their dreams at his camp and
admired him for subverting stereotypes
inspiring others to do the same and
always striving to be his best most
authentic self no matter what we as a
community love pasha for the simple
reason that he has always
undeniably and undoubtedly
loved us back
i just want to say something i miss you
both and cologne you are not my friend
you are my brother my friend
all right well we have it here on camera
that's your that's miles mma expert come
on contradict say something
i think i think pasha's gonna rinse this
guy i think pasha's gonna absolutely
just just just clean this dude's clock
absolutely this guy is not his brother
or his friend he's gonna get
pumped